low key no offense but you know at that
time it felt like it was everyone's
mission to convert everybody but same
thing I thought he was about to say no
offense Jesus is not Korean
[Music]
all right welcome back to a highly
energetic episode of careful oh [__]
turn it up this is the most energy we've
had all year we got Nick and Colleen we
got regular Joe regular Anthony and we
got cool jokes
in the building hey uh here's something
are you are you religious person would
you say uh I would say yes okay are you
like non-denominational Christian
non-binary Christian oh Christian
Protestant all right let's say that you
have to pick a different religion oh
yeah which one is it gonna be yeah
that's a great question and for the rest
of you if you're not religious let's say
you have to pick one oh dude your
lifestyle that's gonna be your house
yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
because Hannah says we have to join a
synagogue
she really said that she's Jewish no
wait what the [__] happening here
because we're we're talking about like
how
okay so we were talking about how kids
do better in a religious community
because it's more structured you also
have like other parents that believe in
the same thing so they'll help you also
teach the same things and you have like
a community effort yeah yeah so we were
just going down the list because I was
like well you're Welsh right and there's
this whole movement in Wales for them to
speak the the the Gaelic again and like
do everything and there's also like a
group that's like trying to bring back
like Welsh witch [__]
you know and I was like but then we need
to give them some time to work it out
because they're so new that not
everyone's on board they don't have a
long like system so we're like who's got
a really good long time system and we're
like well Christians do but they they
still like they're not really connected
but we're like what's the original
Christians and it's like before
Christians Jewish okay so it's like okay
and then they're pretty strict they have
a lot of kids yeah it was between Mormon
and Jewish oh really Mormon because it's
kind of similar right like they have big
families yeah they're they're strict on
their um like that too they have really
big funds they don't drink they don't
drink yeah and then they're strict on
like they promote good habits good
lifestyle yeah so I was like okay those
two are cool yeah but the Mormon church
um I love Salt Lake City but I also love
South Park
and I don't think I'd be able to
um because they did the Book of Mormon
there's some Mormons at like South Park
but they're not real Mormons yeah if
we're gonna do something we're gonna go
like all in hard okay like if I go
Jewish I'm gonna go Orthodox with the
curls and everything wow yeah I'm not
gonna go halfway Jewish how come not we
got a big nose
plastic surgery you can do it you can do
it get the extendo why not the
unification Church the Moonies yeah oh
this too much drama dude why not it's
unpopular in Japan right now because of
shinzuhave yeah the the guy who
assassinated him his parents got ruined
by the Moonies so that's why he
assassinated the prime minister of Japan
so why not go back to Seventh-Day
adventism yeah just go back to what you
know because that's not the prompt
though right too small well you can if
you're not if you're not religious
enough all right fair enough you can go
back to the one that you were raised in
but you said it because it's too small
too small oh you're looking for like a
power Network huh they're not and also
hot take but I don't think Christians
today are as hardcore as Christians
before and like being stern with their
shoes oh yeah yeah that thing like
Jewish Muslim
um yeah most like Jewish and Muslim are
very strict with their [__] sure yeah oh
Amish Christian they're strict with
their [__] right like they're about it
but I feel like all the other Christians
are kind of like halfway in halfway out
they're like yeah yeah it's hard because
it has to be adaptive in some way to
like societal life right it's almost
impossible to be like biblical Christian
and live in America but like yeah like
European Christian I feel like they're
more like I'ma go
ceremonially
like Japanese Buddhists they go
ceremonially They're not really
Buddhists you know so like I want to do
the hardcore [__] if you want to be
hardcore hardcore I'm a Believer yeah
wow I'm like Westboro Baptist Church but
I don't think they're they're hardcore
but I don't think they're good they
sound like a game
that's that's the appeal really
bam yeah what about you Anthony what
religion would you choose if you had to
if I had to you have to Jewish or Muslim
that's it for me that's my final answer
are there Jewish Asians
yeah Rob Schneider I don't know he's
he's Filipino and Jewish is he oh [__]
so I would say uh in the default that I
was raised Buddhist I won't choose
Buddhism but I would say from a
practical standpoint maybe maybe
Catholic
wow I know is Nina your is she well she
also is not religious but it's like
within the family and the whole
Filipinos it's their family value
Catholic is very just it's just
consistent it's present all the weddings
we go to Every you know what I mean it
just is is right there I actually went
to Catholic Church a lot when I was
younger because of like my pseudo-god
parents we were just my parents would
just mix go to church sometimes even
though it didn't make sense
um so I'm like very familiar with it uh
from a non-practical answer
Catholic because of the swag
you like the clothes huh what are the
clothes I said swag I don't know about
the clothes yeah I'm like what are the
clothes what's this no when you the guys
on the stage not you
like the Cardinals he's gonna be
swinging this thing oh the nuns the nuns
in them
like the actual buildings to like the
way that you see him uh portrayed in
like movies you like the Catholic
Pinterest oh yeah you know what I mean
like the mood board yeah you like a mood
board yeah exactly so epic it's just so
[__] you know Regal and [__] got it
very traditional that's important the
churches are always way crazier what do
you think of the priest he likes the
pimp he likes the pimp aesthetic how so
then Gold Cup cane yeah
what are the top three pros of being
Buddhist
you don't have to change [__] if your
food is that's why yeah I feel like uh
you live your life
uh Nirvana there's definitely something
about the idea that like Buddha said he
wasn't like a God and it makes it feel
in a weird way like relatable and or
attainable like the practices versus
like this you know all right yeah like
you you have to service your your entire
being to like try and live in the in the
ways and the in the shadow almost of
something a deity that's beyond your
comprehension so it's all Faith there's
something about Buddhism that like felt
like um I don't want to say practical
and like downplay it in that sense but
it's too self-helpy so relatable in a
weird way why is it that like you said
growing up
that's why you wouldn't go into because
well it's because I was raised like that
my parents are Buddhist but then based
on what don't you like about it though
being that it's not that I don't like it
it's just that like you know when you're
forced to uh you know practice something
yeah when it's your default
sometimes I feel like when it comes to
belief like you kind of have to walk
your own road to believing you know what
I mean but if you're like uh and you
know
bless my parents but I don't think they
were super articulate when it came to
those things and they're not super super
devout I think it was very like
um
traditional and that like we have like a
shrine and you're supposed like my mom
would always yell at me to make sure
that I pray in order do you do the thing
where like if if a relative dies you
have to put like the food on the always
you give your grandma orange yeah we're
always burning the incense I'm always
talking to my my dead relatives you know
what I mean I'm always asking for the
same type of things of like you know
luck and prosperity and like finance and
all that stuff you know it felt like a
like a practice but without like the
core belief that like I found an
understanding of why it's ceremonial
yeah like that's what I mean by like
people are ceremonial is like their
religion is culture and ceremony they're
not devout it was a chore to go to the
to the temple all the time yeah yeah you
know what I mean like the way that my
mom would make it like you have to do
this and you know what I mean it just
didn't it felt like a chore so I don't
think like I grew up with this like uh
innate curiosity of like the belief
system in it
um but I think when I got older learning
about it I thought things were really
there's a lot to really cool yeah a lot
to appreciate
um especially and then things like
Christianity I think when I was
introduced to like God in Christianity
in high school I was I was at a very uh
Korean high school so it was like
Christianity everywhere and I feel like
low-key no offense but you know at that
time it felt like it was everyone's
[__] mission to convert everybody but
same thing I thought he was about to say
no offense Jesus is not Korean
and I remember I remember like you know
especially coming from like a Buddhist
uh household too like one of my aunties
she's a monk right so when you're trying
to learn about a different religion and
stuff like that and you're talking to
somebody who's maybe not the most
articulate as well you can get thrown
off of a certain path I remember talking
to somebody who's trying super hard to
like recruit me into like the Christian
club and convert me and bring them to
the church and it was very powerful at
Sunny Hills High School you know what
I'm saying again all good intentions I
see that very clearly but I remember
having this conversation being like okay
so you're saying
my auntie like she's a monk like a
Buddhist month because she doesn't like
acknowledge Jesus as her savior that he
died on the cross for her sins and so
that she's gonna go to hell
and you know this homie was like yes
either All or Nothing though
removing myself I can get it whether or
not I believe it but a part of that at
that time was so jarring too yeah I mean
you could just run it the [__] is this
would ruin it for you that it would turn
you off initially for sure yeah just
like militant vegans yeah yeah just like
oh I like vegetables but I hate them now
yeah it still tastes like Jesus
I think I was also surrounded by so many
people that like were like this is like
you know I am this religion they they
preach it but at the same time they're
still [__] around like high school
kids you know what I mean like doing all
these other things that are sinful and
stuff so you you just stop believing in
religion you know what I mean yeah you
might still believe in God I do believe
in God but I just this religion I don't
really believe in I guess trust me like
like the aspects of it like some of the
teachings and stuff like that yeah I
think the ideologies I think are [__]
spot on yeah but then you know the human
element of it like is really kind of a
can throw you off if you don't meet the
right people to like guide you and I
just don't feel like I met those people
but it's very hard to meet the right
people exactly which is why I like I
question it because very I feel like
very seldomly the most enthusiastic
person trying to talk to you and force
you is usually not the right person
there's just the person wanting to score
the most points they're just allowed
commenters because I probably was that
person at one point were you did you
grow Buddhist too what the [__] is that
supposed to mean no I didn't was it I
wasn't judging you yeah exactly I wanted
to make you I want to make you look like
based on any particular physicality I
want to make you look like a bad guy you
gotta look like Buddha another more like
Confucianism yeah yeah yeah dude
um no we didn't grow up religious at all
no in no kind of way whatever my dad
would always and I've talked about this
before
um my mom wanted me to go to a private
school when I was in sixth grade because
she didn't want me to get beat up all
the time so it's like oh let's put you
in a Christian School in like a couple
of our friends were going to Christian
School they liked it so like hey let's
push in a Christian School you know at
the time they thought it would be a
better education and it kind of wasn't
but
um it wasn't better than public school I
don't I don't think so I don't I I
didn't think
um you didn't have smaller classes and
it was easier to get to know your
teachers none of that happened yeah it
was cool but I feel it was like a net
neutral like okay how many people did
you have in your class it wasn't that
many it was like it was our seventh in
so which religion would you join that
Christian it was a Christian school but
um I think I would do
I don't go Muslim bro shut the [__] I
got a full muscle around why it's my man
why because the cubby copy bro that's
why I fell out loud that's so funny okay
look the one thing and I think this goes
for all the religions across the board
right we all know tons of people who
claim to be very religious but they're
all Hypocrites exactly they may not show
exactly they may not their lifestyle may
not represent
their beliefs and their religion if you
look at it like that's could be like
maintained a pretty good demonstration
of proper like I'll say this I think I
think some of the dudes are like
that are Muslim a good amount of them
the nice thing example wise tend to be a
lot more disciplined in their life
because they have to
adhere to adhere to a lot of it right
especially when it's like ingrained in
their culture but then again you could
have there's obviously way more examples
of that not being the case and I think
that's like that for any religion you
know like of course yeah because human
nature is always going to overpower like
that concept right because we know what
what needs to be done the discipline
side but I think in for some for a lot
of people that are Muslim it's built in
just because of like the daily practice
right like a lot of them do the um the
Ramadan when they do Ramadan I think
that kind of builds that in especially
you grow up with that but then again not
always the case but for me I would think
I'd give that a spend in yeah not always
the case but it is true when you see
Muslim people really being Muslim it's
kind of dope yeah like I like that I
think that's what I like is I like
people in communities that that practice
what they preach so exactly if I look at
like all the Christian communities I
would say like Amish Mormon like they're
so hardcore like that I'm like okay you
guys are about it yeah see that's what I
was thinking like if I'm gonna go into
religion it's gonna be in the same
school of Joe like we're gonna [__]
really do that but also we only find the
hypocrisy when we're close to it
definitely so like that's the reason why
we know so much about so my number two
yeah people look at us and go you don't
eat pork yeah they think and I'm like
that is pretty true they do they're
strict with their food yeah yeah I think
my number two is like I want to join a
mega church dude I kind of think that's
like the opposite dude the Joel Olsteen
[__] yeah I want to do a [__] mega
church you want to get the uh because I
bet the Sunday Services dope the
gemstones baby you know because it's a
whole event the whole family comes out
you there's obviously a big junk and you
know take everything that we're saying
with a grain of salt because there's
always drawbacks right in my head I just
wanna like they have a band dude they
have a whole [__] and their preacher
comes down a like a a zip line a zip
line and they believe this preacher
isn't talking through him like Chris
Brown on the strings he's not talking to
a bikes he's talking through this thing
and he's it's wireless yeah the he has a
Janet Jackson concert it's a tiny little
oh Mike I'm into that I'm into I'm into
that I want to be a part of that kind of
fresh dude see it's about the swag
sometimes kind of like it's just see you
being in love with that yeah because I
think it's the community part right I
think that's the cool thing everybody's
attracted to it everyone's correct not
going to like [__] like Rome or
something like you go into a St Peter's
Basilica you're you see some [__]
gangster Church you're like
God was here and then you go to like
these random like Christian like hatan
churches or something like that on a
strip mall yeah it's just like in the
strip mall it's just in a building
you're just like man that belief is here
but that's where you want to be dude hey
but you know what being part of Faith
here yeah that's where you want to be
dude God is love the church is gonna
it's gonna also cost you Mega more
that's fine dude I'll I'll work to the
bones for for the [__] Jesus gonna be
like 90. I believe if I truly believe
that my religion is gonna be my path to
Salvation then yeah bro I'll give
[__] 15 percent
Olive Garden freaking liar dude I'm a
good temper bro I'm a good temper I do
like eight percent just the tip I want
to be a part of a group though that's
like hooked up so like if I hooked up
yeah so like
talking about games
I think it's the same all right because
like it sounds like
I don't know like what if what if like
Biden went to your church and then so
like you could be like hey dude you know
I need a job and he goes well you could
work at the White House okay because
like if you're in a connected religion
you know
like everybody works together yeah
that's true so it's like you want to be
with a successful group if a cult hits
me up and I see what they're doing and
what they're wearing and where they're
I'm like man you guys aren't successful
oh yeah like yeah what if a a cult like
a good one y'all wearing Quicksilver
dude if they came over and they're like
more of a billabong guy yeah
we're like we yeah they all Drive Lambos
yeah they're like a pyramid sites yeah
yeah well you know what's interesting
we're talking about religion in such a
way that it's like the lifestyle and the
practices of like our this existence but
not really referencing like the
afterlife elements
damning these religions completely
because if we was going there then I'm
like yo you know I've always been
curious about the whole 70 virgins
waiting at the doorstep [__] you know
come on over brother
oh he sounded I was like whoa yeah
there's 70 in cells that show up yeah
hey we don't know that yet but it's a
good Community he gets there and they're
like oh we thought you were a virgin
[__] no one thinks this guy's a virgin
come on everybody what about what about
you Colleen you gotta pick one I'll
probably flip Anthony's flip Anthony's
only because I uh went to a Catholic
private school in elementary school and
I felt like it was very much let's push
this narrative down your throat you
can't ask questions if you did you'd get
in trouble I'd get call home uh calls
home and my dad would pick up and I mean
I've said this before he'd be like
double stop asking questions and my mom
would be mad at it what kind of question
would you ask as a kid little Colleen
I'd just be like what do you mean that's
what Jesus would do
that's funny
it's a good question how do we know
about it how do we know that I mean I'll
just won't do that it's just what he
would do I'm like
it just did it never it's never
satisfied it never satisfied me so I
don't know I'll be a Buddhist that
sounds pretty chill no
it all it all comes down to the
articulation I think that is such an
important part you know what I mean
you're like trying to like teach
somebody how to like live their life and
like its greatest purpose and you're
educating like a kid who hasn't like
come to terms with like the world yet
and how it works and then you're not a
good articulate person so it's like I
actually like a lot of religion after I
studied it on my own yeah yes that's
very true when you're running into
[__] morons and they just don't know
how to speak yeah they're just like well
[__] you I don't like you so because I
don't like you and you like religion so
much yeah I'm not whatever you are yeah
the same reason if someone were to stop
the freeway whatever it is they're doing
that for I hate it yeah yeah or or
outside of the supermarket when they ask
you to donate you're like I don't care
about women oh that'd be the worst I
don't care about Wheels now I don't I
usually love whales but now I hate them
[Music]
okay